even if the expanded universe has taken
the time to answer some burning
questions the Star Wars films are
absolutely packed with fascinating
mysteries some of which may never be
addressed again here are just some of
the biggest questions Star Wars has yet
to answer the prequel trilogy is all
about charting the rise and fall of
Anakin Skywalker from the boy with tons
of potential to hotshot Jedi two Dark
Lord of the Sith that all begins with
qui-gon jinns realization that Anakin
whose midi-chlorian ratings and natural
talents seem off the charts must be the
chosen one when he relays his suspicions
to the Jedi Council mace windu brings up
quote the prophecy of the one who will
bring balance to the force
Yoda mace bygone and obi-wan Kenobi are
all very aware of this prophecy and
Anakin's chosen one narrative continues
right up to the moment he loses his
lightsaber duel with obi-wan in Revenge
of the Sith
so the prequels are very clear that a
prophecy exists and that it's well known
among Jedi Masters but what the films
don't make clear is exactly where the
prophecy comes from who first
articulated it how long has it been
around does every Jedi take it seriously
or do a lot of them believe it's made-up
hogwash that has no practical
application when it comes to protecting
the galaxy and what does bring balance
to the force even mean when the Jedi
believe that they've long since defeated
thus if the original trilogy makes it a
bit of a point to never explain much
about Yoda the enigmatic Jedi Master who
lives on the swamp planet of Dagobah and
even pretends he's not who he really is
when he first meets Luke Skywalker just
to teach the young apprentice a lesson
in expectation versus reality I'm
looking for a great warrior all we
really know about the little green guy
in those original movies is that he's a
Jedi Master
he taught obi-wan and he can teach Luke
the mysteries surrounding Yoda combined
with his unique appearance led many fans
to wonder what the Masters backstory
really
and in particular if the alien species
he belong to would ever be revealed then
the prequels came along and while we
certainly learned more about Yoda's day
job as the head of the Jedi Council we
still didn't learn much about his
background the mystery only deepened
when the Phantom Menace introduced a
second Jedi Master Yoda who seemed to be
of the exact same species
piecing some kind of connection that
might pay off in a future film it didn't
of course and while there are certain
supplemental stories you can dig up out
there for many fans Yoda remains a
mysterious figure and that's just the
way they like it
the Star Wars films are full of famous
death scenes that might not always be as
final as they seem the second film in
the saga reveals that even after obi-wan
Kenobi dies he's able to come back as a
force ghost something Yoda is also later
able to do the prequels have taken this
a step further with solo a Star Wars
story carrying on the story told in the
Clone Wars TV series which revealed that
the Sith Lord Darth Maul did not die
when he was cut in half and thrown down
a shaft by obi-wan Kenobi in the Phantom
Menace he somehow survived that fall and
managed to get himself a sweet new pair
of legs but surely that can't be true
for other force using warriors who fell
in the prequels right as it turns out
maybe it can in 2016 while answering fan
questions via twitter samuel l.jackson
declared in my mind mace windu is not
dead he justified his theory by citing
the jedi ability to fall from great
distances and land safely after all we
don't really see him dying in revenge of
the sith which does raise some questions
when compared to all the other scenes in
which we clearly watched jedi getting
cut down speaking to Entertainment
Weekly later Jackson even said that he'd
gotten his theory co-signed by George
Lucas he told the w George is like I'm
okay with that you can be alive so if
you believe Jackson mace windu is still
out there having one handed Jedi
adventures somewhere what other Jedi
might have
made it out alive the first time we see
a Jedi Master die in a new hope obi-wan
Kenobi simply vanishes when Darth Vader
swings the lightsaber through his body
the second time we see a Jedi Master
died in Return of the Jedi
Yoda quietly disappears from his sickbed
both Jedi leave a pile of clothes in
their wake but nothing else something
Luke Skywalker also did when he perished
in the last Jedi for a significant
amount of time in Star Wars lore it
could have been forgiven for simply
thinking that Jedi Masters vanish when
they die but that changed with the
Phantom Menace
when qui-gon jinns body remained in
place after his death as did the bodies
of numerous other Jedi during the purge
in Revenge of the Sith so why do some
Jedi vanish and others don't
is it based on their force level do they
train themselves to do that or is it
simply that some choose to remove their
own body from the mortal flame while
others don't care the movies never
explore this apparent inconsistency but
they almost did Revenge of the Sith was
set to reveal that the vanishing act had
something to do with a discovery that
qui-gon had made in the afterlife but
the scene was cut the longer you sit
with the deeds and words of obi-wan
Kenobi in the original Star Wars trilogy
the more frustrating some of his various
decisions become yes obi-wan saved Luke
in a moment of crisis gave him his
heirloom lightsaber and started to teach
him the ways of the force but he also
seems to have been determined to obscure
the truth as much as possible
particularly when it came to who Luke's
father was obi-wan obviously could have
chosen to spill the beans right up front
that Luke's father was Darth Vader but
held off on that and it's death said
that Vader had betrayed and killed old
Papa Dukes things get more complex when
you start to factor in what obi-wan knew
thanks to the events of the prequels
which reveal that he was not only there
when Anakin Skywalker turned into Darth
Vader but was also there when Luke and
Leia were born and there when the plan
to separate and hide them was hatched
they also hung out a lot with r2d2 that
obi-wan doesn't seem to acknowledge that
Leia is
Luke's sister or ever acknowledged that
r2d2 is an old friend just adds another
layer of confusion to his thinking there
are reasons for some of it now but
there's a lot of head-scratching going
on here perhaps no other character in
all of the main Star Wars saga has been
present for as many historic moments as
r2d2 well maybe c-3po can compete with
him but unlike artoo Threepio had his
mind wiped at the end of Revenge of the
Sith so he can't very well look at Darth
Vader and realize oh dear that's my
maker r2 on the other hand has a memory
packed with fascinating moments and
galaxy altering events from the birth of
the Skywalker twins to the turn of
Anakin to the whole of the Clone Wars he
was there for all of it as far as we
know from the film's he hasn't forgotten
any of it
so why doesn't he speak up seriously the
prequels ritual actively add a ton of
moments to the original trilogy where
artoo could have simply said hey she's
your sister or hey remember me we hung
out together during the Clone Wars even
hey that guy built you Threepio would
have been relevant instead he remains
silent for reasons that are unknown to
us all we have our theories and a hope
that perhaps one day artoo will break
down and explain himself at the end of
Revenge of the Sith Bail Organa obi-wan
Kenobi and Yoda have a conversation
about the future of the Skywalker twins
now that their mother has passed away
obi-wan says that the children should be
hidden where the Sith cannot sense them
and Yoda declares that it's better to
split them up and hide their relation to
one another obi-wan takes Luke to
Tatooine to live with his aunt and uncle
while Leia goes with Bail Organa to
Alderaan roughly two decades later
during the Empire Strikes Back Darth
Vader begins to understand that he is in
the presence of his long-lost son and
eventually tells Luke that he's his
father it makes sense that he might not
have known it until then
particularly if he never made time in
his busy empire-building schedule to
head back to Tatooine but what about
Leia when she and Vader first cross
paths in a new hope it's clear that
they've known each other for some time
he's aware of her skills as a leader
why doesn't he ever seem to sense that
she's his daughter is she somehow
holding him off with her own limited use
of the force is he just dismissive of
the very idea of it because she grew up
so close to him the films never make it
clear but Vader definitely had a closer
connection with one twin than the other
the sequel trilogy decided to keep up
the Star Wars tradition of a shadowy
figure pulling the strings of darkness
by introducing Supreme Leader Snoke a
humanoid alien who in the force awakens
only appears in the form of a giant
hologram that film gave us very little
to go on about Snoke all we really knew
was that he led the first order he
trained kylo Ren he wanted to destroy
Luke Skywalker and by extension the Jedi
though certain supplemental materials
have since shed a little more light on
Snoke even the last Jedi didn't give us
much more information before
unceremoniously slicing the supreme
leader in half and ending his reign over
the first order it seems possible that
the upcoming rise of Skywalker will
offer more details about him but it's
equally possible that the film will be
so concerned with moving forward that it
won't spend enough time looking back to
tell us anything new about Snoke so who
was he why was he a dark side force user
but not a Sith
why was he obsessed with the Skywalker's
how did he carve out the first order
from the remnants of the Empire in such
a relatively brief period of time the
answers to these questions like so many
others might very well be lost to the
void in Star Wars The Force awakens we
finally learn what happened to Luke
Skywalker's first lightsaber the one
passed down to him by obi-wan Kenobi
from his father which he lost while
dueling Darth Vader in Cloud City or at
least we learned part of what happened
to it the lightsaber was locked away in
the possession of Maz Kanata at her
castle on takodana but when Han Solo
asked where she got it
Maz only answers that she's had it quote
for ages the matter of how it came to be
and her possession is left equally
mysterious in the context of the force
awakens Maz shrugs this question off
because the first order is attacking and
the movie can't slow down to hear a big
information dump about the lineage of a
laser sword
but that hasn't stopped fans from
wondering exactly how Maas ended up with
the lightsaber Luke dropped it along
with his hand on best spin more than 30
years before so how long are the ages in
which it's been in Mazdas possession why
didn't she tell Han about it before did
she have it even before Luke vanished
and if so why didn't she try to give it
back to him perhaps the rise of
Skywalker will give us answers but it
seems quite possible that the film will
be too busy with other plot points to
touch on it check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Star Wars are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]